You scroll all the way down to the end
of the report, you realize, "Oh, it was
in a church and the people killed were
Christians." And then you scroll some
more and oh, the attackers were Muslims.
Okay? And then they tell you it was
because of, you know, climate change
pushed one group to attack the other.
But it has nothing to do with the Islam,
just to be clear. All right? That's what
they'll tell you.
So, we're supposed to ignore all that.
That's not real. And let's focus on
what's happening with what happened in
New Zealand. That one aberration. Okay?
Bec- Why? Because that one aberration
gave them what they want. The excuse to
shut down free speech on Islam in this
case. And that's exactly what
Islamophobia is. What's that word mean?
I told you, it's fear of Islam, but they
want you to treat it it's a sickness.
You have an irrational fear that doesn't
make sense and we got to we got to, you
know, fix you. But all that stuff that
Muslims do, their doctrine, their books,
their history, current events, yeah,
that's just you're crazy. It's not
really happening. It has nothing to do
with the religion. So, what if they
stand and quote the Quran and say Allahu
Akbar and, you know, Muhammad commands
us to do this like like the um
ambassador told Thomas Jefferson. So,
what? You know, you're you're you're
misunderstanding. You're an Islamophobe.
That one one attack, the Christchurch
attack, the the two mosque attacks, 51
people being killed, the UN wants you to
believe that that's a pattern and it's
in dire need of recognition, response,
and amelioration. Okay? And what is that
response? Well, it's to shut down all
those who dare connect the dots like I'm
doing and say, "Oh, Islam's actually has
a heavily documented pattern of violence
and abuse and discrimination against
non-Muslims." And in in the current case
I gave you, blowing them up in their
churches or burning them. And by the
way, make no mistake of it, that is
precisely what March 15th means today,
combating Islamophobia Day. It means
nothing more than shutting people down
from connecting the dots like I just did
and letting you know actually it's Islam
that's doing all the stuff that they
want people to think Islam suffering
from and islamophobia is actually a
natural and organic reaction to Islamic
behavior all around the world. Okay?
So that's what the UN is doing. That's
what March 15th is. Combat Islamophobia
Day. If you ever wanted, you know, a
perfect example about the UN and all
these official bodies of how much they
lie and deceive and are so hypocritical,
here it is. Think about it. We've set up
a day, March 15th, because oh my god,
someone killed 51 Muslims in their
mosques. Horrible. How can that be? And
we have to commemorate that day and
remember it forever. And we have to do
everything possible so that doesn't
happen again. Meanwhile, that is an
aberration. It hasn't happened again. It
doesn't happen again. And actually it's
Muslims who are continuously and
constantly attacking and killing and
persecuting Christians including in
their churches.
That we ignore. That's not happening.
That's not real. That's not worth even
talking about passingly. But we're going
to use the former and we're going to
create a whole day about Islamophobia
which is again dedicate another way
another word dedicated to shutting you
up so we can't talk about what I just
talked about and connect the dots. All
right? Bring back
the fire
Bring back the fire
in the
righteous name.